alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ugh
je ne sais pas ce que je fais
quoi oh bien sûr maman est devenue célèbre merci merci
vraiment assis
bon garçon
disco garçon
cuisiner avec gordon ramsay c'est comme
oh mon dieu je sens que j'ai mal pour  tous
les gens qui ont fait ça avant
leur vie d'accord posez les crevettes
bien à plat là-dedans oui non non non non non
non
je fais des erreurs
nous venons de commencer
d'accord à partir de là tomates oui
poussez et tirez en arrière poussez et tirez en arrière
faites  tu sais que cette
[musique]
c'était hilarant et génial et je veux le
refaire
bonjour regarde
voici la conséquence
conséquence conséquences de mes actions qui
me poursuivent en ce moment je ne veux pas de
conséquence conséquence conséquence je
ne veux pas de conséquences  me poursuivre
en ce moment quelqu'un prend cette conséquence conséquence
conséquence quelqu'un prend
cette conséquence de me poursuivre en ce moment
jeJésus
[Musique]
toi